hello everyone i've had a really busy
work week uh so i did not watch the
nintendo direct because i
you know had work while it was live and
it seems like a whole bunch of trailers
have dropped this week and just totally
passed me by because
you know i have a job
so now with a small chunk of spare time
that i have i thought that i would catch
up on a bunch of the trailers that i
have missed that i feel like everyone's
been talking about for the last few days
um mortal kombat snyder cut and then
i'll check out the
major things from the nintendo direct
that i missed because i don't even know
what the major news was
but we are starting with mortal kombat
trailer because that dropped today and i
did also want to talk about an article
um from jezebel that a lot of people
have been talking about about the
trailer um
so we'll do that we'll watch the trailer
first though so let's
go first learned about this seven years
ago
on a mission in brazil to capture a
wanted fugitive
that's cool get it cool when we got
there
the tour through our unit in seconds
[Applause]
i'm into it superhuman abilities oh my
god hang on
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm gonna
[Applause]
that's some mortal kombat that's amazing
oh gosh you'd love to see it
[Music]
i'm guessing focusing on sub-zero it's
the birthmark
what do you mean he was born with it
it's not a birthmark cole
means you've been chosen throughout
history
different cultures all over the world
reference a great tournament also so far
everyone's hot so that's cool
that dragon marking i always love that
in my action films i think it's an
invitation
to fight for something known
oh my god
oh my look i don't know what it is about
the extreme violence of mortal kombat
that always makes me laugh
is there something wrong with me i don't
know what it is
but that stuff is so funny to be fair
okay
i think any movie that has extreme goal
like this does
does get a laugh out of me but
i know you're not supposed to be into it
but i love it i think it's
it's fun there might be something wrong
me
she said the name of the film she said
it's mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonia
that's kano i'm luke
jackson
the fate of earth is in our hands
every time am i missing it or is it
further ahead
no i'm making that mistake
[Music]
that's the first cg that's looked bad
i am
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god
the song too that's smart wow
how is there still this much left of it
how's it going he sounded like he was
actually australian
um okay so
loved it had a great time uh
what i will say is they definitely like
clearly
have have focused on making sure these
characters look like their video game
versions
that's super cool um the fact that
there's a little montage of everyone
saying their names which
you know means absolutely nothing to
anyone who hasn't played the games means
this is a thing that's going to focus on
fan service i would guess
uh it will make sure that it is true
to the video games though i actually
feel like a lot of the
um the fate of earth is in our hands
mortal kombat multimedia stuff has
actually been pretty good i found a lot
of it to be really fun
i don't know if this is going to be like
a good film
but i feel like it's going to be very
fun to watch is what i'm going to say
um that is a very fun trailer i wonder
what the the reception has been i always
like
i often find out that my perception is
so different to everyone else's so
game chops uh this trailer was a
flawless victory
get over here everyone else you said it
pretty happy about it so that's great
yeah so now i wanted to jump to this
jezebel article that asks the
great question of why chun li
has not been featured in the trailer
very confusing for a lot of people let's
jump over here real quick okay here we
go
uh who forgot to invite chun li to the
mortal kombat
a lot of people been talking about this
one uh i have a take of my own
cinema is back baby and in a big way
forget the artur films of awards season
where two people stand at the edge of a
cliff somewhere in great britain pining
for each other but never finding a way
to make their relationship work
there is a new model combat hitting hbo
max and life is [ __ ]
good but then it goes on to ask a very
important question
but being the astute film critic that i
am i immediately clocked a glaring error
in the film
where in all the realms is chun-li if
there is a battle for the fate of earth
then don't we need all the greatest
warriors gathered which would include
chun li and her spinning bird kick that
kanaka man's head clean off
sounds like a pretty big plot hole to me
that the ultimate street fight
is supposed to be won by a ragtag team
held by sonia blade
and sonia blade no offense to the sonia
stands uh and then they issued this
update
that says update 4 39 pm
jezebel has discovered the answer to our
question about chun-li's erasure and it
is that chun-li is not a part of the
mortal kombat megaverse
wow so i kind of don't even want to show
this
um which is the thing that i goes
against my rules a lot of the time
uh is i don't like to tell you that
people on the internet have been saying
something and not give you evidence of
people on the internet saying something
but in this case it feels like i would
be making fun of them as individuals
i'm not comfortable with the idea that i
would be like pulling up tweets to mock
these people i don't it feels too
personal because of this content so what
i will say is first that this is posted
at 4 20 p.m specifically but to follow
up from that
um ultimately people on the internet
not necessarily saying a lot i'm sorry
that i'm not sourcing them again it's
something that i
usually really strictly do uh have been
posting this article by shannon
malero and um just really vocally
talking about how
uh it's it's wrong essentially
and that games journalists are all
terrible journalists in general suck
because oh my god how could you not know
that she's a street fighter character
and is not in model combat
here's my take as someone who
quite often posts jokes and have people
not understand that they're jokes this
is a joke
i feel like it's so clear this article
isn't real it's a troll article uh
it just seems so obvious to me and all
these these tweet threads that i'm
seeing people being like this is an
example of journalism being terrible
there are many examples of bad
journalism there there were
articles today where i was like this is
awful this is this is
just just atrocious uh you didn't source
anything
your facts are incorrect this is
absolutely terrible um
but this one is not one of those because
it's a joke
if you think sounds like a pretty big
plot hole to me that the ultimate street
fight is supposed to be won by a ragtag
team held by sonia blade
with ultimate street fight in it is not
a joke
also being the astute film critic that i
am i immediately clocked in a glaring
error in the film
it's clearly sarcasm this is clearly a
joke
and i feel like people are using this
update here
uh to say jezebel has discovered the
answer to our question about chun-li's
erasure and it is that chunny sort of
part of the mortal kombat megaverse wow
that just they're like no this proves
that it was how stupid can you be
life comes out you're fast it's like the
kind of stuff that i'm seeing
this is just them doubling down on the
joke okay
you all got trolled you can look through
this this person's articles and read
them and see the difference in the
writing uh you can also go to her
twitter
i'm going to advise that you do not
harass her which naturally a lot of
people have been
but here's the framing tweet uh joseph
here said well i have to know i really
absolutely have to know the chunley
thing was all on purpose right
this is what she responded with
come on